[Music]
there will never be another like Freddie
Mercury so you can only imagine the
casting the movie Bohemian Rhapsody must
have seemed like an impossible task but
you know what they found their guy mr.
robot star rami malek it is almost eerie
the way he channels the legendary leader
of Queen in these brand-new scenes I'm
playing Freddie Mercury how about that
you sing well I think I will sing a
little bit I will sing a little bit why
not
rami malek does more than sing he
transforms into the iconic Queen
frontman Freddie Mercury dude again one
more how many more Galileo's do you want
no pressure
now I'm stoked to the biopic covers
Queens formation in 1970 Ready Steady
Lester and portrays their legendary 1985
live a reunion hailed as their greatest
performance ever
[Music]
the film also tackles Mercury's
sexuality the speculation into the
fiercely private stars personal life was
a media obsession at the time
Freddie deciding a private life what
more do you need to know I make music ET
sat down with mercury in 1982 and he
talked about his need to captivate the
audience I'd like to feel that I'm
dominating everything I don't want an
audience sort of taken over I mean I
have to slip I'm like the mother
sometimes I can go over the top
surviving band members Brian May and
Roger Taylor produced the music for the
film Malik told Stephen Colbert about
the intimidating recording process you
had to sing as Freddie Mercury in front
of the other members appointed well how
did they take you they took me
[Music]